Speaker 1: Let's go next to Alex
from California. Alex, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. So have
you covered the 62nd, 60 minute
interview from Joe Biden and about Taiwan?
Speaker 1: I covered the interview in terms
of Biden saying that the pandemic is over. I did
not cover the Taiwan piece. I was so busy early
in the week that I didn't even watch the entire
interview. I just did a story on the acoba part.
Speaker 2: Okay. So I'm curious because every
time Joe Biden says something about Taiwan life,
if China invades, we're going to send troops.
But every time that happens, it always seems
that the White House always backs pedal and say,
oh, we don't know about that or, oh, we don't
stand by that. What do you think about that?
Speaker 1: I think it's typical posturing.
It's you you you say something, the president
says something, a little hawkish. And then when
there's a request for a clarification, you sort
of walk back a little bit and say it's not our
intent or it's not what was meant. I think that
that is completely standard political posturing
to sort of keep those that you consider
your adversaries a little bit unbalanced,
where it's not totally clear exactly what they're
willing to do. It's like a minor version of when
Putin talks about launching nukes. I think
it's just typical posturing. It's politics.
Speaker 2: Right. So if let's say somehow or
for some reason, China does invade Taiwan.
Yes. Do you do you believe that America should
step in with their like not just like what,
sending funding to Taiwan, but like sending troops
like American troops to. Like, how about Taiwan?
Speaker 1: I am not ready at this point in time to
say that the U.S. should get involved militarily
in defense of Taiwan against China. I believe that
China would be wrong to invade Taiwan, of course,
but I am very careful about declaring support for
American military interventions. So right now,
I can't tell you that I would support
that. I would have to study the issue more.
Speaker 2: That's fair. But like, I feel like
if, you know, China does invade Taiwan and I
feel like that would set like a bad precedent
if America doesn't do something because
like you can't Ukraine is doing well because
we're sending a bunch of aid to their way.
But in the case of like China and Taiwan, I
feel like this is like a really different.
Speaker 1: Situation at this scale is completely
different and the circumstances are completely
different. Listen, I agree. I think that military
action would ideally happen in coalition, and
I am not at this point ready to say that. I
would say, yes, the U.S. needs to get in there.
Speaker 2: One final thing. Do you
believe that people are people are
comparing like the China-Taiwan situation
to Russia and Ukraine and saying how
how Russian is doing poorly and how things are
now going in Russia's favor during the war. And
people believe that that might reflect or might
be the same situation if China invades Taiwan.
Speaker 1: I think that that is a totally
different situation. I do not think it is
logical to extrapolate from how Ukraine is doing,
how Taiwan would do. I don't think that that would
be a fair assess, a fair assumption.
Speaker 2: Okay, Sister. That's all,
David. Different for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you. Alex
from California. Very, very important declaration.